Hello there and welcome to
this delicious slice of internet.
Dan how's it going?
Yeah good.
Having a good time?
Yeah.
I've always wanted to
film a cannon in slow mo.
Me too.
Luckily people at Captain
Morgan White Rum have
provided us with this nice
cannon here and some drinks.
Thanks Captain Morgan White Rum,
we appreciate it.
For the cannon.
So we've got we got cannon and
a load of sort of odd
looking drinks to fire at.
Guess I'm aiming on the go,
can't miss these drinks.
How would you rate your
cannon aiming skills?
Top top.
Pretty top.
Top yeah.
Top of the line?
Never missed with a cannon before so,
it's going to go like this.
And it's gonna go like this in slo mo.
Bit of spin.
I'd be well annoyed if you
knocked those down right now.
So I'm going to film
this on the Phantom flex,
two and a half thousand frames,
which is 100 times
slower than your eyeball.
And hopefully it'll look a bit gnarly.
Oh let's do it.
Okay firing.
Good shot.
Not a bad shot.
Yeah pretty good.
GoPro survived.
A bit disappointed I missed
like three of them actually.
Pretty poor effort.
Oh there's the ball down here.
Bloody obliterate it
Oh here it comes.
Wallop.
Oh look at that annihilated it.
It really just didn't
care about the glass.
It's just like what?
Straight through.
I can imagine the cannibal
like looking back,
like what was that?
So while we're getting additional angles,
do you wanna explain what you did?
Well we were using the
GoPro to try and get
a good shot of the sort
of cannonball going past.
Yeah I'll cut to the
footage of that right now.
Oh wait I can't because
you absolutely mauled it.
I'm sorry.
Nothing not nothing left.
Look at the bloody memories cardholder.
That's salvageable.
It's got like the,
there's no data on it.
You blew the date out of my memory card.
Literally a direct hit.
Yeah go for it.
Standby firing.
Ooh.
You hit the camera?
Success.
That was a lot of fun.
It was that was good.
You absolutely mauled those drinks.
Yeah perfect straight line through.
Good aim.
That was good fun.
I think I'll take one of
these back with me actually.
Well we actually made two other videos
for the Captain Morgan YouTube channel.
So you can click those links
here they're on the screen.
Give those a click check them out.
Subscribe to us subscribe to them.
Follow us on Twitter all that go for it.
Cheers.
Job Done.